let me ask this question so the nuclear
bombs have only been used twice in
history in Warfare right but they've
been tested over 2000 times you got an
article that just came out here about
China saying China's vertical nuclear
expansion is real most concerning is the
prc's modern and grown nuclear Arsenal
more precisely the significant vertical
expansion and increase in the number of
nuclear warheads of this Arsenal in the
hands of such disabled destabilizing
force it needs to be confronted
post-haste by Public Accounts the PRC
had approximately 240 nuclear heads in
2010 today it's at 350 by 2030 they're
projecting to have around 1 000 Beijing
will continue the largest ever nuclear
force expansion and Arsenal
diversification in its history Beijing
it's not is not interested in agreements
that restrict its plans and will not
agree to negotiations that lock in U.S
or Russian advantages right okay so if
it's only been used twice it's been
tested two thousand times
and everybody is concerned about people
having nuclear bombs and everyone wants
to have them like what do you have in it
for you know because if one starts and
it triggers and it's really a nuclear
Ward that happens worldwide what's going
to be left over if they go that
direction why is everybody so obsessed
with having nuclear bombs
it's the Assurance of mutual destruction
so I will say like there are countries
where you could look and they're their
willingness to give up the nuclear bomb
resulted in us exploiting them I mean
look at Libya I mean that is a great
case study on you know pursuing nuclear
weapons we convinced you to get rid of
it and then we topple you
um you know you could just keep going
down the list with that but I I when
looking at history feel like when a
country has nuclear power at least the
United States uh seems to respect them
more and I mean Pakistan is a great
example where if we really wanted to win
the war in Afghanistan at any point
Western Pakistan was the talibans United
States of what United States use Kuwait
for to facilitate Logistics is what the
Taliban used in Pakistan but we didn't
want to go in there because there were a
nuclear power so
I think if I was a country that would be
something I would get because if you
don't have it and they do they're going
to treat you with less respect
interesting it's just purely about you
know making sure you have a little bit
of Leverage and protection that's an
insurance policy that's exactly it's
something you may never ever use but
just the fact that the other person
knows you have it they give you a little
more respect that's right I think the
phrase that gets used and I don't mean
this in an ethically derogatory way but
there is a phrase out there that says
it's a Mexican standoff which means that
you're both kind of stalemated I mean
look at North Korea as an example a tiny
little Peninsula and the
they're on the world stage because they
got nuclear bombs and that's literally
probably all they have or people
probably have to eat nuclear pieces of
bombs for and breakfast but people
forget what he's doing right his his
nuclear capabilities are actually you
know 1980 grade at best but what does he
keep testing the ability to deliver them
he keeps launching the inner inner the
the missiles that are unarmed so what
he's showing everybody is that he's
increasing his rocketry technology so
that he could deliver a bomb but his
actual nuclear capabilities are more
meager but it makes one crazy guy with
one dirty bomb and the ability to
deliver it into downtown Tokyo not just
a menace now he's got a chip at the
table
yep
interesting so you put the story up
Tyler North Korea fires powerful missile
using old playbook in the new world the
last time Pyongyang launched a weapon
was over Japan in 2017 When Donald J
Trump was President Kim yong-un seemed
intent on escalating conflict into uh
with uh Washington and if you recall
that's exactly when Trump was like I
would release great fire and fury that
whole thing and people are like he's
gonna start World War Three and next
thing you know him and uh Kim Jong-un
are exchanging love letters it's
probably when Millie started collecting
up the nuclear launch codes and
and what's what's Wild is nothing
happened in four years that's what's
Wild nothing happened in four years
everybody was just kind of sitting there
saying let's wait for this guy this uh
this this guy to leave and then if we
want to do anything let's do it
afterwards boom he's gone next thing you
know Afghanistan and all the other stuff
started not during his Reign but it
started right after him and they tried
to capitalize because maybe they were
concerned he was going to do something
about it so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]